single mom and assistant principal
denise winchester
wrote into our show and she's been
sleeping in her living room for the past
10 years
and has finally moved into her very own
room
and now she needs our help redecorating
the living room without breaking the
bank so here she is now hello denise hi
drew i'm so happy
thank you
now um you have been sleeping in your
living room for the past 10 years may i
ask why sure um
around a little over 10 years ago my
daughter and i moved into our apartment
in manhattan
it's a pretty tiny apartment as they are
in manhattan uh but it has two bedrooms
and it also has what i like to call the
world's tiniest living room
so
obviously i wanted my daughter to have a
room so she immediately non-negotiable
got like the good room you know
that's how it is that's how we do right
and then um but i saw an opportunity
there and i said you know
i'm gonna rent
what would be my room and that left me
in the tiny living room and we're
talking about a tiny box right but you
know when you're a mom especially a
single mom
you do what you got to do right
um any parent does i think so i did it
of course to save money for bills and
the necessities but i feel like
more than that i wanted to give my
daughter like
an awesome childhood like all the new
york city experiences that you know i i
probably wouldn't have been able to
afford otherwise i wanted to give her an
awesome birthday party every year
all the holiday events and just just
everything i never wanted her to feel
like she wasn't worthy of all of that
because she is
and i never wanted her to feel deprived
and that's why i did it and i would do
it again
[Applause]
well your daughter is here with us um
waverly
hello hi hi cutie
how old are you uh i'm 13. what does it
mean for you
to see your mom make these choices well
i'm really thankful like i'm thankful
that i got to have my own room like i've
been i've slept on the couch before it
isn't really that comfortable and just
to see that she did that for like like
over 10 years and that's just that
really made me really grateful like she
did that so i could have my room and
that just it makes me feel really
grateful for her
[Applause]
the second that i found out that she got
her own room i was so happy i made her i
made her like a sign for her room like
the minute that i found out she
had her own room
there it is
[Applause]
so
in the hopes of creating this new space
that you so deserved and that you've
worked so hard for um what are your
hopes in redecorating what are you
looking for
well
you know the room we've always had so
much fun in and we're fun people um i
feel like you know there's a space
challenge there's you know that's just
how it is um it has like zero
personality i feel like we have
quite a bit of you know personality and
it has no charm no character no
personality and we're not comfortable
there we're like literally physically
not comfortable you want to be inspired
yeah yeah it would be awesome and you
want it turn key and taken care of and
like the ideas and just i would love it
i have magic wand
oh oh please yeah and i i obviously
don't want to break the bank and i am
any inspiration would be so appreciated
okay well i know a human magic wand um
he is drew crew member and interior
designer to so many people if i listed
their names like you would just freak
out um mikal welch and he is going to
help us design the space on a budget and
i would love to see what he's cooking up
with this design on a dollar with macau
take a look
hey drew i am so excited to create a
beautiful living room for denise but
here's the thing i definitely want it to
be functional and it cannot break the
bank i'm gonna hit up some thrift stores
i'm even gonna do some online shopping
this is going to be the best makeover
that denise has ever seen
whenever you're doing a home renovation
project the most important thing is
finding the budget and definitely
sticking to it
always try to shop for things that you
absolutely love whenever i'm in a thrift
shop i give one once around then i go
back again and if i really love it
that's when i pick it up one of the
nicest things about shopping in the
thrift store is that you can find things
that are good for the environment but
also good for your wallet as well so for
instance take a look at this chair right
here this is a beautiful piece you can
oftentimes find really good bargains on
things that are current
this could work
it's the lampshade that's the problem
if i find a simple white lampshade this
gives her that bling that she likes it's
acrylic this is the answer
i've got my big purchase here if you
could just let me know the final number
on that of course make it a good one
drew likes a bargain
that is 25 today you are speaking music
to my ears
that's a win
so now that i'm back at the office there
is one other place where you can go and
get a big bang for your buck and that's
right here from your own computer when
you're shopping you need to find people
who do not understand the true value of
what they have if i'm looking for a
fancy mid-century modern sofa i will
never
write that out you need to stick to
people who have layman's terms such as
the word couch the person selling the
couch doesn't know what they have and
you can typically get your price point
much better whenever you're shopping for
items you want to make sure that you
actually go and see that piece in person
at least do some type of video call so
you can see the piece and make sure that
it's in good condition
i can't wait to show denise what we have
been working on in order to transform
her space she's an amazing mom and she
deserves this makeover more than anybody
but most of all i think she's going to
be impressed on how i didn't break the
bank
[Music]